you don't have the money problem you
have a mindset problem so that a great
question for one of my loyal YouTube
viewers Jonathan love you guys who wrote
in to say Thank You Evan my passion is
to bring awareness to addiction and
mental illness through my feature film
potholes that I'm writing with
award-winning actress Tina Lehmann based
on my true story and also through my
childhood character Barry Blue Bunny but
I feel stuck financially to get these
projects done and you need to paint
incredibly amazing artists and talent to
have an amazing product I also want to
get help to develop an app but yet again
the money thing this is a story that a
lot of entrepreneurs tell themselves if
I don't have the money to do fill in the
blank that I won't be able to be
successful and as long as that's your
mindset then you will never be
successful you have to understand that
it's not about the resources you have
but how resourceful you are it's not
about how much money you have but how
you use the money that you do have to be
successful and yes money can help but if
you look at the resources you have money
is never the number one resource you can
throw as much money as you want at a
problem and it's not gonna go away
the number one resource you have is your
passion and you need to tap into it to
adjust your mindset and start achieving
some results with this project here's an
example say somebody came to you and
said Jonathan I'm working on this
project is a video idea that helps
alleviate mental illness and awareness
and bring attention to it I want it to
be big I wanted to impact a lot of
people's lives I wanted to be a really
meaningful project I really need your
help because you have skills that I
don't have that can help move this
forward what would you say to that you
would be on board in a heartbeat because
it means something to you I do projects
all the time because it's going to help
entrepreneurs because it makes me feel
good and because I feel like I'm making
a positive contribution to the world
those are the people you need to find
the people who are just like you who
have that same passion that you do but
have complementary skill sets reach out
to them with passion let them know what
you're trying to do and let them feel
that their involvement will have a
positive impact on the world and focus
your efforts this has to be important to
you if the video
means something that the video is really
that important to you then put your
energy on that don't worry about other
things like building an app you have to
be willing to put in the hard work the
effort the sometimes years that it takes
to build the right team to make this
thing happen are you willing to do that
because if you're not then you don't
have enough passion to drive through the
finish line and you're gonna
consistently blame a money problem as
being the reason why you're not able to
be successful so stop blaming money as
the reason for you not achieving your
goals you already have everything you
need to be successful when you adopt
that mindset then you'll start seeing
forward progress believe if you guys
like this video you want to see more
just like it subscribe to the channel
thank you so much for watching and I'll
see you soon cowboy yay personality I
subscribe to Eva's newsletter a few
years ago it has really helped me the
newsletter is very informative and
inspiring and it has helped me
throughout my career so I encourage you
to don't give up you can make it
subscribe to Emma's newsletter today you
won't regret it
you